Centuries ago, in a small tucked away kingdom, ruled a royal family.
The family was known for rich land, blossoming mint and cocoa bean supplies.
The crown prince was set to marry the neighboring and much more powerful kingdom's daughter.
However, there was one open secret throughout the kingdom.
The prince and his maid were... in relations.
Everyone in the palace knew, but kept the information away from the princess, for they knew she could have a temper.
Until one night, the princess dropped by without warning and caught the prince.
While the princess set the kingdom ablaze in a jealous rampage, the valiant prince stood by his lover and fought for their right to love.
Or so you would think.
Instead, the prince buckled under the first sign of trouble and immediately threw his maid away to save his skin.
And while burning at the stake, the maid uttered a curse upon the land and vowed to...
Ugh, I can't believe I'm having to study today of all days.
I really shouldn't have procrastinated this history report.
But when my oshi said she's going to be making a big announcement, I can't miss it.
I'm so excited.
Oh, it could be a new song or a new outfit.
I can't even focus on this book.
I just hope it starts soon.
Ah, oh my god, oh my god!
Oh, Spaghetti-chan, Spaghetti-chan, you're so cute!
Uh, is this thing on?
You're so cute!
Good morning!
Marinara and cheese, a perfect blend of meat.
I'm a maid you'll want to wrap around your fork and eat on up.
A meal even a college student can make.
I'm spaghetti-ing it!
Spaghetti-chan!
Everybody, with my lovely group of girls, anything is possible.
But now, it's my turn to follow a different recipe.
And that's why I am announcing my graduation from Hidden Dreamers.
Huh?
Graduation?
No way, no way, no way.
This can't be happening.
Spaghetti-chan, no, no, no, no.
This is just a bad dream.
Spaghetti-chan, Spaghetti-chan, Spaghetti-chan, Spaghetti-chan, Spaghetti-chan, Spaghetti-chan.
SPAGHETTI!
My bum.
Huh?
What's going on?
Oh my god.
Am I dead?
Family?
Who was my family?
Who am I?
I don't know anything.
I don't even know how to tie my shoes.
Oh god.
What do ghosts even do?
Do I say boo?
Do I say bleh?
Oh god.
What's this?
Get a job.
Excuse me?
Get a job?
Oh my god.
The audacity.
Like, come on.
Can't a girl catch a break here?
I just died.
Like, I know I asked, what do ghosts do?
But like, I didn't mean like, I need an answer right now.
Give me a break.
Come on.
I don't even know.
I don't even know where I am.
I don't even know anything.
What's 2 plus 2?
Who even knows?
Like, this is ridiculous.
Just, can't I just have a moment?
Gabe!
Yay!
Thank you!
Yeah, I mean I just got here.
Why not relax a little bit and play a little bit of video games, huh?
Yeah.
And I think I better get out of this weird forest.
I don't know why I'm here.
But I think the computer just set on fire.
So, let's just find the nearest town and set up shop.
Trick or treat.
Um, hello?
Hello?
Yeah, I'm talking to you.
Excuse me.
Um,
hello?
Yes, uh, it is me.
Could you lower the game real quick?
Yeah, you know, I'm just trying to have a conversation with you and all that fun stuff.
Yep, yep.
Hello?
Uh, hello?
Hi.
Yeah, could you put your game down?
You do know you're like paying per hour for this table, right?
Oh my goodness.
But there you guys are.
Okay.
Yeah, hello?
Hi.
Yes, so...
Now that I have your attention.
Yes.
I know you have been waiting to see the wizard.
And it is finally your chance to see...
The wizard.
So, yes, um, I hope you are prepared to see the wizard.
And, um, uh, yes.
But before you see the wizard, uh, unfortunately I will have to blindfold you.
The wizard is very private, okay?
Um, the wizard has his ways.
So, um, you know, I'm just gonna have to blindfold you real quick.
I hope that's okay.
And, um, yes, just give me one moment.
One moment, please.
Okay, okay, yeah.
The wizard, yeah, I know you have been waiting very patiently.
The wizard is a very, very busy wizard, okay?
So I know you've been waiting...
I don't know.
I don't actually know how long you've been sitting here.
Um, but the wizard is now available.
So, um, just give me one moment.
Okay, let's blindfold you.
Okay.
Okay, um, give me one second.
I'm blind... you're blindfolded, right?
You can't see anything?
Okay, um, just give me one second.
Uh, you might hear some noises.
You might feel me touching you.
Um, don't freak out or anything, please.
Thank you.
Okay.
Okay, um, just one second.
I'm setting up.
Okay, um, all right.
I believe we're just about done.
Uh, wizard, are you... are you...
Oh, gray and powerful wizard, are you prepared to see your next, uh, subject?
What do you call it?
Um, yes!
Okay, the wizard will see you now.
I am the wizard.
I know, lost souls, you have come to see me seeking wisdom from my brain and beyond.
It is I, the wizard.
Yes, look upon my orb.
It works very well.
Yes, I am the wizard.
And I know you are a troubled soul.
You've come to the right place, seeking guidance.
Yes, I understand you're wanting maybe answers that...
...life can't give you, but the afterlife may have what you seek.
You see my orb?
It is how I talk with the spirits.
And how I make really funny faces when I'm by myself.
Yes!
Now...
Wait...
Um, hold on.
I must use my third eye, which is also very real, to look into the orb, okay everybody?
Are you ready to...
I don't know, is this a seance?
Um...
You know, my wizarding ways have no...
Okay, hold on, let me turn off this mic.
My wizarding ways have no explanation, okay?
You may feel and experience things that you...
...may have never experienced before.
Yes.
Um, and um...
I know we talked about like the...
...like the upfront fee.
Um, you know, but uh...
Um, anything that happens, there's like a spirit summoning fee per minute.
And um, what else do I have here?
I have a third eye fee.
For how long I have to use my third eye, which is basically the entire time.
And then I have...
You took up...
You took up a seat.
So uh, we have a chair fee.
Okay, we'll just go over it like afterwards.
You know, it's all good, don't worry about it.
What do you require, wizard?
Visa?
Mastercard?
Oh, we accept all sorts of payments.
Um, so yeah.
Are you ready...
...to gaze into the beyond?
I must see you say yes.
My body is ready.
Yes, yes, yes!
Um...
I made a connection.
I've made a connection.
Oh, wait.
Wait, something's actually coming.
Wait, something's coming through for real.
This is maybe the first time this has ever happened.
No, this is not the first.
I mean, this is my powers at work!
Now, what is that?
That you see?
This spirit is...
...doing...dancing...something.
What the hell is it doing?
Oh, yes.
These magical powers.
Look how spherical my orb is.
It's kind of impressive, isn't it?
How...how round it is.
The feet...of a spirit!
Have you ever seen a spirit before?
Say no, because you've never seen magic quite like this.
This is real!
These are my real powers of my third eye and my magic hat.
That's from...
...a place called Club Penguin.
And...round.
Whoa.
Oh, good.
This...this spirit has not only just shoes, but also socks.
Good, good.
Good to know.
Oh my goodness.
I have to use the...
It's...the spirit's going kind of crazy.
I have to use my mouth to simulate sound effects.
I don't think the socks are edible.
I don't think so.
Oh my.
We even have a knee.
Oh my gosh.
A knee.
A spiritual knee.
Wow.
You could say even a Nico Nico knee.
Oh my goodness, another knee.
Won't stop you from trying.
You can definitely try.
You can definitely attempt.
Oh yes, indeed.
Oh, oh.
When I dance, the spirit also dances.
How peculiar.
Oh my goodness.
Oh my gosh, dance party.
No way.
Wait.
Oh my goodness.
Whoa.
What the...
That looks unsanitary.
Unsanitary spirit.
Clean up after your food.
How dare you just let it drip all over you.
That's disgusting.
There's just chocolate.
I hope that's chocolate.
There's spiritual ghost chocolate all over this leg.
Now that might be edible.
Not quite sure.
That might be edible.
But what about this?
Wait a second.
I just noticed something.
You know, this spirit is kind of copying my style.
Except I have a frilly band and the spirit has a different band.
Okay, copy.
We can't both be wearing the same outfits.
That's so embarrassing.
Somebody has to change.
Somebody has to change, okay?
Okay.
So embarrassing.
For real.
Okay, spirit.
What else do you got?
What else do you have here, spirit?
Oh, and also...
Whoa, the thigh is really close.
Don't go licking it now.
But even, you know, ribbons on the back and the such.
The spirit's really giving us a fashion show.
Not close enough.
Yeah, let's...
Even the spirit agrees.
Disgusting behavior.
This is a spirit, guys.
This is no longer living.
You can't simp for a ghost, okay?
Once we know...
Once we fully form this ghost's form...
We can ask it any question about the universe.
We can ask it anything that we want to know.
The spirit is all-powerful and all-knowing because I summon them.
Oh, wait a second.
This really is...
What?
This ghost is really stealing my style.
Except, this also has like a little kind of locket-looking...
I don't even know what to describe that as.
I think the ghost is...
Maybe, perhaps, the ghost is familiar with my game and is cosplaying the great and powerful wizard.
That must be the case.
A buckle!
Yeah, a buckle.
Thanks, guys.
It's a buckle, yeah.
Oh, the skirt is so poofy.
Just like mine.
No, we can dance together.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, break it down, ghost.
Break it down.
Oh, my god.
Whoa, the ghost is going crazy.
I gotta match their energy.
Oh, my god.
Wow, whoa.
Oh, my goodness.
Who is this?
What?
Look at this dapper, squishy, mochi-mochi-looking fella.
He's quite cute, wouldn't you say?
Oh, I think the ghost agrees.
Yeah, he kind of looks like my guy, but a little more...
I can't tell.
Sleepy?
Something's...
Something's a little different.
They're like...
They're like brothers.
But this is the chill brother.
And mine's the anxiety brother.
Very squishy.
Yeah, very...
Oh, my goodness.
He's like really dancing up in there.
I think he likes the PGM.
The cooler brother.
The cooler brother, truly.
The ghost is continuing to move.
Hey.
Ghost, show us your face.
I command thee.
I command thee, ghost.
So we can know your secrets.
I summoned you here.
And so I will have you...
Say...
I will have you spill the tea.
Not yet ready, I think.
But it seems here we have...
Maybe halfway?
Or I guess more than halfway.
It's half of...
It's the waist.
It is the waist.
Hmm.
Interesting.
The cute little buttons there, huh?
I wish mine had buttons.
Oh, lucky you, huh?
Lucky you with your buttons.
Oh, okay.
Maybe the wizard will sew some on later.
I don't know.
I'm a very busy wizard, I guess.
I suppose.
What's this too?
Oh, the arms are up.
Why?
Why are...
Oh, my arms are also up.
Why are our arms like that?
Well, of course, I do it to make the ghosts feel comfortable.
I'm not a ghost, I'm a wizard.
But this is a ghost.
And this is how ghost's arms are.
Except it's really deformed, because it's...
Because it's in a orb.
Okay, guys.
My crystal ball is maybe deforming things a little bit.
In fact, I believe it's deforming this part quite a bit.
Wow!
Whoa!
Spirit, what are you...
What are you showing off to us?
Oh, my goodness, Spirit.
I think things may appear larger in the orb than they appear.
Wait.
Things may...
Hold on.
Things in the orb may appear larger than...
Than they are.
I think.
Oh, my goodness.
Yes, things are...
I don't know.
Things are...
I'm a wizard.
I know.
Actually, we will know, though, once the ghost shows their face.
Now, ghost, show thy face.
Ghost!
Oh, we're close.
I can see the neck and also another buckle around the ribbon.
How cute.
Ghost!
No!
I command thee, come back!
Ghost!
Uh-oh.
Hold on.
You guys need to pay more for my third eye to work better.
Did we summon another ghost?
Perhaps.
Did we summon a different ghost?
What is this?
Hmm.
I'm gazing into my crystal ball.
Oh, it's getting bigger.
It's getting bigger.
Oh, my god.
What is this creature?
What have we summoned?
Oh, my goodness.
Oh, my god.
It's disgusting.
What is this?
Oh, my god.
Oh, my...
It's bald!
Wait a second.
Every time I talk, it also talks.
Creature.
But it's bald, so it's definitely not me.
It's definitely not me because it's bald.
The creature has hair!
The creature.
This creature is disguising itself as me.
How could this be?
Everything I do, it mimics.
What is going on?
What is happening?
Why did my BGM stop?
Oh,
you guys.
You guys, I don't think this is an ordinary creature.
I think this is my ghost!
Guys, I have a confession.
I'm a hack!
I'm not a real wizard at all!
This is a hack from Club Penguin!
I'm not a real wizard!
I never wanted this job!
Oh, my god.
I'm gonna leave town.
I'm never gonna show my face again here.
Oh, I think my establishment is about to explode.
I think we...
But, I mean...
I mean, I gotta get out of here!
Noooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooo!
Oh, I forgot to turn the filter off.
It
is I!
The great spirit that was trapped inside the orb!
And I have been released!
Oh.
I also forgot to turn the filters on.
There we go.
Yes, that wizard was a hack.
And...
Now I'm here...
To...
Be...
The ultimate ghost maid!
This isn't like...
You guys saw the outfit.
So I guess I'll just... Oh gosh, I'm so nervous.
I'm nervous!
Okay, well, I'll...
I'll talk a bit.
And then I'll have some karaoke as my first order of being the great ghost maid.
To...
So...
Oh gosh!
Why are you nervous?
I don't know!
It's so new!
Oh my gosh, I'm like...
Because I've been waiting...
Since this was announced, I've been waiting a whole month and now it's finally here.
And it's kind of like one of those things where it's like...
Am I allowed to show this?
Because...
Because for this whole time it's been like...
A quote-unquote secret!
Oh gosh!
Okay, I'm gonna rip the band-aid off.
I'm gonna rip it.
I'm gonna rip it off.
Wait, hold on, let me turn my BGM... I just noticed the BGM is a little quiet.
Okay.
Because I have things I gotta talk about before the karaoke.
So...
Okay.
Oh gosh.
I'm playing it cool.
I'm playing it cool, don't worry.
Hi.
Oh wait, I just noticed something.
Hold on.
Oh no!
Okay, I'll have to fix that later.
I accidentally deleted something on my OBS.
So...
Hi!
Stop!
Don't look at me!
Oh gosh, I'm so...
I'm so nervous.
Oh my god.
Oh gosh, I'm so nervous.
Thank you guys!
Thank you!
Welcome...
To...
The almighty powerful...
Mint!
Here, I'll zoom out a little bit.
So you guys can see a little bit more.
More.
Wait, maybe I should get rid of the desk.
It feels naked.
Feels naked.
Hello, hello.
Hello, hello, hello, hello, hello, hello.
So, welcome to my...
My third and final...
And I guess I should show you guys some things.
Hold on, let me zoom in here.
Suddenly zoom.
Yeah.
I don't know what to do.
I don't know what to say.
Honestly, I didn't even plan up to now, so...
I didn't even plan up to here.
The smug is strong.
I know, I can be so smug.
But I guess I can show you some of my other expressions.
Oh my gosh, wait, I'm doing the Vtuber thing!
Oh my gosh, I'm doing the Vtuber thing!
Okay, okay.
So...
Did I include this?
Hold on.
I forgot something.
But that's okay.
I'll include it...
When I get to there.
Yeah, because there's some stuff that...
We didn't have time to finish before the debut.
So they'll be coming a little bit later.
Yeah.
So...
The pointy ears are new.
Oh my gosh.
You guys are kind of insane.
Because I was like, you know what?
Yeah, I'm a ghost.
I can have pointy ears if I want.
And then suddenly, all this fanart of me with pointy ears started happening.
And I was like...
What did I leak?
I was like...
How did you guys...
How did you guys know?
I can't have any secrets!
It's so unfair!
Are you guys me?
Maybe when I possessed you guys, some of my thoughts went into your...
So I have some expressions that I'll show you and stuff.
So...
Okay.
Some I want to save for later.
So I'll show you guys just kind of...
So I can also have my arms down.
Oh yeah, here's me.
Hello!
Hello, hello.
Can I take your order?
Or I can have them up, of course.
This is more natural for me, honestly.
Hands real.
So...
And don't leave because after I show you all this stuff, we'll do the karaoke and I have some special guests.
If you want to watch the karaoke and stuff...
I know that's like people leave once the reveal happens.
But...
Show the hands.
Let's see my hands.
You can see it without the orb.
My skirt is so flowy.
It's very ghosty.
Because I'm a ghost.
Oh!
One of my favorite things though.
Look at this.
Look at the sparkles on my...
On the little buckle.
Isn't it so cute?
Little sparkles on the buckle.
Okay.
So, I can...
I can...
Yeah!
Oh my gosh.
I don't...
How do Vtubers do this?
I'm scared.
And...
Let's see.
I can also...
Someone said smug earlier, huh?
Well...
Uh-huh.
Okay.
I'm freak phantom.
I've literally have seen your tweets.
Seen your tweets.
Unfortunately.
Yeah, caught in 4K.
Lude woman!
Me?
You!
Not me!
This is me side-eyeing you.
So...
Yeah, I can be extra smug now.
And...
For when I'm always panic mode.
Which is...
No!
This one I had before too.
I always feel very panicked.
So...
Yes.
Yeah.
This is literally me.
Right now, at this very moment.
And...
I have...
I think some of you guys like this kind of expression.
And then if I do this too...
Now I'm extra disappointed.
All my spiritual energy has been drained from my ectoplasm body.
I'm taking emotional damage.
Literally at this very moment.
Oh, it hurts.
Yeah.
And...
Let's see.
I can...
Oh, this one's kind of fun.
So this is when you guys are waiting for my stream to start.
Hold!
Is she gonna start on time?
Is she gonna start?
Oh my god.
We have...
We have just one minute left.
And the VTuber's not here?
Oh...
Why did my tongue come out?
But I like to combine it with...
Oh my gosh.
This is the best thing ever!
This is me whenever I play Metal Gear Solid!
No!
Oh my gosh.
Solid Snake!
Blizzcon!
Actually no.
You guys, look at my ears.
When I blush.
Oh gosh.
Yeah, my ears get red now.
It's kind of embarrassing.
No!
It's kind of embarrassing though.
Stop looking at my ears.
You freak.
Stop looking at my ears, you freak.
Freak.
So yeah, this is my blushy blush blush blush.
Which you'll never receive.
And...
Let's see.
Oh wait.
I want my arms back up.
And...
I have a couple more.
A couple more.
I wanna save a few of them for later maybe.
Let's see.
Oh here.
And then...
You guys!
When you're so mean to me!
Stop being so mean to me!
Bully.
No bully.
Okay, okay, okay.
No bully!
But of course I can also...
Be sad and...
Sad, but you know, happy sad.
I'm like...
That's kind of how I feel like right now.
I just feel very...
Emotional.
Very grateful.
Oh my gosh.
You guys!
My 3.0!
Finally happened!
And I mostly had no...
Mostly no scuff I think.
Maybe.
And then...
Oh, of course.
I have...
My tongue.
I can't be a ghost without my tongue.
Yeah.
I can...
So the...
The eye and the tongue emote will...
Change.
It looks a little...
I think it actually looks a lot less like panties.
But I didn't test it...
In the...
In the emote thing.
So I guess we'll...
I guess we'll find out.
So now you're probably just like...
Oh my gosh.
Everything is so new and shiny and...
Who created all this awesome stuff?
You had so many things that happened...
Today.
Right before...
You appeared as you are now.
So I'll go over my credits and then we'll get into the karaoke.
I think...
I have time.
I think I'll be okay.
Wait.
I have some other stuff too.
This one is kind of interesting because I...
Didn't expect it.
But this will be for my...
Emo song hours during karaoke maybe.
Watch my hair.
Tonight will be the night that I will fall for you.
My hair grew.
Crazy.
Crazy, crazy.
And that also brings me to...
Another hair related thing.
These were not done in time, unfortunately.
But, like I said, it will happen...
Sometime soon-ish, I think.
Soon-ish.
But I have two hairstyles.
Two more hairstyles that...
Wait, does that work?
Hold on.
Okay, there we go.
That will be joining me.
The first one is...
Twintails!
Oh my gosh!
So kawaii!
Twintails!
Actual, real twintails.
Oh my gosh.
I'm gonna look like a real...
Like a real man.
I mean, I am a real man, but...
And then the next...
Will be...
Looks the same so far.
Long hair!
So, sorry that they couldn't be done for today.
But, please look forward to them when I can include them.
Whenever that is.
I know, it's so long and elegant.
Oh my goodness.
Oh my gosh.
But for now, you're stuck with me.
For now, you're stuck with plain Jane Minto.
Okay, so...
Was that everything?
Oh, no, I did have...
Sorry, I forgot some other phrases.
I forgot this one.
For when you guys are particularly...
When you guys are particularly deserving of jail time, probably.
Death penalty!
Jail!
Go to jail!
Do not pass go!
Do not collect $200!
Jail!
Neko Mint.
I can be like a clock.
That was weird.
Be good now.
Be good.
Okay, credits time.
Credits, credits, credits.
I'm going to scooch up right next to you guys.
I'm going to bring my desk back because it's quite lonely without it.
And...
And credits!
Okay, hold on.
Pause.
First and foremost, I want to do a special thank you to, of course...
Ichikamaya for helping finalize my 2.0 design.
Because, you know...
Even what I have now, how I look now is with help from Maya.
And so, I of course want to...
Thank her, there we go.
And of course, to 1.0 and 2.0 Mama Keiichi, our Mama!
So, thank you.
Thank you so much, Mama Keiichi!
Thank you!
So, yeah.
Of course, even though I have 2.0 Mama and everything...
Of course, I'm so grateful for Mama Keiichi for bringing me to life.
Well, after life.
To begin with.
So...
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you!
Yeah, and...
For credits for the main stream stuff...
Sorry, I meant to say...
See, this is what Maya helped me with.
So, up in the top left corner is kind of what I drew.
And then, Maya really fleshed it out and helped me with picking a bunch of hairstyles and things like that.
So, that's how I became to be in this.
Like this.
And look at this, she did all of this.
Even the reference sheet that I have now, she did for free and everything.
She's so, so sweet.
Thank you, Maya!
Thank you!
Yeah, yeah.
She had all these little hairstyles drawn out for me and everything.
I was like, oh my goodness.
She put so much effort into it.
I was really grateful.
All those years ago.
And let's see.
Next.
Was it obvious?
My mama!
Oh my gosh, I can finally say this.
Ayami mama!
Ayami mama is my new mama!
Yeah!
And she made me so cute.
What do you guys think?
You guys... How are we feeling, huh?
How are we... How are we feeling?
Do you guys like it?
Cute?
Yeah?
Yeah!
Thank you guys for all the superchats and everything, by the way.
I really appreciate it.
Sorry that I haven't been able to really read them and thank you guys.
Yeah, thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you!
And then my papa is Celia!
Which... Oh my goodness.
Celia is just so cracked and...
Thank you, Celia!
For making me move and being so attentive to things.
Oh my gosh, one of my favorite things about... Look at this.
Look at my ribbons.
When I move, they're so puffy.
Right?
They're so like... They look 3D.
I remember when I first sent the picture of me to Matara.
She was like, oh, your 3D is getting started?
I was like, girl, no!
This is 2D!
I'm not 3D yet!
It's crazy, right?
Like they're so... She did such a...
And like the little sparkles on the buckle and everything.
Oh my gosh, Celia is amazing.
So, so amazing.
So, you might recognize...
Celia also is Limu's papa and Doki's papa.
So now we're all like sisters.
Ayami!
I love you with all my...
Ayami papa!
I love you!
Thank you!
Everybody say hello to Ayami mama.
Why do... Why did you send that?
No!
I had to fight her to send more money, honestly.
And then Crunchy helped Celia with setting up the project file.
So thank you for that, Crunchy.
And for the opening animation...
Oh my gosh, did you guys see the new opening animation?
That's by artist Yodoke on Twitter.
It's so cute.
Oh my gosh.
I kind of like gave them a list of things that I was like...
Oh, maybe you could include this or maybe this.
But you don't have to include everything.
It's okay.
And then they included everything.
And they went all out.
I was so happy.
When I got it.
Show it again?
Oh, yeah.
Let's show it again.
One second.
Yeah, so thank you Yodoke.
And then the opening music that you heard is by Mitsukiyo-san!
Mitsukiyo-san, thank you!
If you don't recognize that name...
Mitsukiyo-san is one of the main composers...
for a little mobile game that I like called Blue Archive!
So, actually...
I'm so grateful now that I went to Anime Expo.
Because when I was there, one thing I really wanted to do was...
I was like, I'm going to introduce myself to Mitsukiyo-san.
Because I want to work with him.
So I was able to give him my card.
And then when I was getting this started...
I was just like, you know what?
I'm going to shoot my shot.
And see if maybe he'll do my intro music.
And he said, oh, you know...
I haven't been taking personal, you know...
Non-corporate requests lately.
But I got your card at Anime Expo.
And I liked your style.
And I saw you're a fan of Blue Archive.
So I will work with you!
Yeah!
Because I networked at...
Because I networked at Anime Expo.
I got to work with Mitsukiyo-san.
So, yes.
And the song is so catchy.
It's so great.
And I think it was funny because...
Some people...
My last...
My last opening intro video had like...
Welcome to maid world and stuff like that.
But the song actually...
Titled by Mitsukiyo-san is Hello Ghost World.
So we're still ghosting...worlding.
Yeah!
So...
Yeah.
We're still technically welcoming...
Or going to a ghost world.
A world.
Yeah!
So I was really happy about that.
And you haven't seen it yet.
But the ending animation is by Mushroom.
I really love Mushroom's pixel art.
So you'll see that at the end of the stream.
And the BGM that you're hearing now...
And the ending BGM is by Jun.
Which, if you watched...
Mintamatarou's summer special...
You might recognize that name because he did a lot of editing.
A lot.
He did all the editing for us.
So...
Yeah.
Actually, it's cute because I wanted like a song that...
Tied in with the...
Like, I wanted two songs that...
Were the same but not.
So this is like a...
Kind of like a toned down version of...
The ending song.
So they're...
They're like...
This is like, I called it the Twilight version.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And then I feel like I never got to do a proper...
Like, introduction of...
The cafe background.
But it's by Marie.
Which, she also did another background.
A new one that you'll be seeing...
Soon.
In fact, in like a few minutes.
In like a few minutes.
Yeah, lower five version.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Exactly.
And then...
The chat is by Jason.
So thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
It's so cute.
You guys are little ghosties.
Yeah.
Another.
And then, there's more credits.
Because...
I had that lore video at the very beginning.
Thank you, Seven Star Studio.
Thank you, guys.
Leah, Esper, Azu, Apocay, and Vesson.
Thank you, everybody.
For working with me on my lore video.
I kind of like, threw them a script.
And threw them the idea that I wanted.
And...
Oh my gosh.
The coolest thing was like, they...
Created that...
Like, POV.
And it was like a...
Real, like, 360 world.
It was...
The coolest thing ever.
I was just like, wow.
Oh my gosh.
And so...
Yeah, I was like...
And then, they brought Spaghetti-chan to life.
My oshi.
I hope you guys liked it.
I came up with the whole script.
Maybe that...
For better or for worse, probably.
Spaghetti-chan really graduating?
Or was that just a bit?
No, she did graduate.
Yeah, Spaghetti-chan.
She graduated.
Spaghetti-chan!
So sad.
I'm over it.
Kitchen Dreamers.
It's the best...
Idol group...
Made idol group ever.
Marinara and cheese.
A perfect blend of me.
Rest in spaghetti.
And...
So yeah.
Thank you, Seven Star Studio.
For such a...
Oh, and oh my gosh.
I didn't ask if I could...
If I could...
Share it...
Before...
So I won't.
But the...
Drawings...
Like in the...
In the...
Sketch part of the video.
Of the lore video.
Was all like...
Hand done.
And then she...
Like with pencil and stuff.
And then she scanned it.
And so...
It's just...
It was like...
Very authentic.
It's very...
You know.
I was like...
I kind of want like a storybook...
Looking vibe.
Yeah.
Thank you, Seven Star Studio.
You guys are amazing.
Thank you.
My...
I wanted something really...
You know.
I'm not really like a lore...
Video type person.
I wanted something just kind of...
More silly and goofy...
Than anything.
So...
Hopefully that kind of...
Came across.
Hopefully.
And then last...
Another thing you guys might have seen.
Yes!
Wait.
Hold on.
I actually...
Let me pause the music.
Because I think I still have it up.
I do still have it up.
I actually...
We're about to run out of time in the game.
This...
Is the actual game...
That you...
Will be able to play...
After stream!
Yeah!
So...
I basically...
Went to Joji...
And I was just like...
I...
Okay, there was this one game...
I used to play all the time...
On Cartoon Network.
It was like called...
Trick or Treat...
Beat or something.
And so...
I really wanted something...
It always...
Put me really much...
Into the Halloween mood.
And so I really wanted something...
Just like that.
And so we came up with...
With Phantom Freak or Treat!
Yeah!
So this will be...
Available after the stream...
For you to play.
The freaking watch...
I made this.
The little overlay...
I made it myself.
And...
There's four levels...
That you can play.
There's lots of...
Vtubers in there...
And lots of Vtuber references.
I asked...
A bunch of like...
My indie friends...
And people...
That I was just like...
Whoever...
And there's some other corpos...
In there as well.
So...
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Go and find them all...
And collect all the treats.
And at the end...
There's a Parade!
So...
Yeah.
There's...
I wanted to...
Honestly include more people...
But...
There was a...
Time...
Time was not on the side.
But I tried to include...
A good...
Amount of people.
And...
The team was absolutely...
Crazy.
Oh!
And all the music is also...
Custom.
So if anybody wants to stream this...
Playing it...
I don't know why...
If you want to...
I don't know if you want to...
But...
You totally can!
Because the music is...
All...
Commissioned from me.
So...
Or rather...
I commissioned it...
For other people.
And...
Yeah.
So...
And...
Oh.
Whoops.
Oh my gosh!
I forgot to credit that!
Wait.
No!
Guys, I'm so sorry.
Oh my gosh!
I'm such a failure!
I forgot to put the music credits...
In the game credits!
I'm so sorry!
No!
Oh, I'm so, so sorry.
But it's...
It's on the...
Itch.io.
So, it's definitely there.
But, yeah.
Joji...
Did, like, a lot of the programming.
He had a friend...
Also help, but...
He doesn't have a Twitter or anything.
He's just some guy.
So...
Sorry, Escalito.
You have...
Salary...
Salaryman.
That's your picture.
And then Lou did the art.
Electra also helped with the animation.
And...
Oimo is the illustrator for the parades.
It's a very cute picture.
I think you guys will like it.
And then...
For the music...
This song was done by Fingers.
Which...
I feel so awful right now.
Fingers on Twitter as well.
With a...
With a one.
Fingers does a lot of, like, metal gear.
Yeah, Fingers from the Kojima Frequency.
Yes, yes, yes, yes.
So...
He...
Created this.
And it sounds just absolutely exactly what I wanted.
Very, like, old school, you know?
Show their Twitters?
Oh, you know what?
I can do that.
Hold on.
I can just do that.
Wait.
Twitter.
I can go to Twitter.
Wait.
Oh, no.
I don't wanna look at...
There it is.
Okay.
Wait.
What about this show?
It's probably fine.
Okay.
Oh, it's really...
It's really small.
Fingers!
Fingers on...
Oh my gosh.
It's really small.
Hold on.
There you go.
Fingers on Twitter.
Like that.
And then...
The other song, which...
Hold on.
Oh, everything is all messed up now.
This is so scuffed.
Hold on, I'm gonna refresh and see what song we get.
The anticipation.
It's silent.
Oh, because I didn't click on it.
Oh, because I didn't click...
My bad.
This is by Daryl.
It looks off-centered because it is.
This is its own thing.
This is its own thing, you guys.
Hold on, let me get the...
Let me get Daryl's...
Um...
So...
Oh, why is it...
Oh, there we go.
At Starlight Daryl!
Thank you, Daryl, for the other BGM, which you might recognize.
Daryl...
Helped with the...
With my original intro music, so...
Thank you so much.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So yeah!
That's the game.
Again, it will be available after...
After stream, I still gotta make it public.
So...
Yeah, okay.
I think I...
Are you guys ready for karaoke?
You guys ready for karaoke?
And if you find any bugs, just tag me or something, I don't know.
Put it in the hashtag.
So that I can see and then we'll try and fix it.
Yeah, okay.
Give me a second.
I'm gonna go back to my loading screen so I can set up, okay?
Give me one second.
I forgot something.
Hold on.
Now I'm ready.
Okay, I'm just gonna sing a song...
To warm up and then I'll bring in my guests, okay?
Wait, I didn't bring up anything first.
I'm not gonna do a lot of songs, I have a karaoke tomorrow.
So...
Look at this, you guys!
We're finally using the stage in my maid cafe!
Yay!
We can finally use the stage in my maid cafe.
I can get a little bit bigger.
Yes, I can get closer.
Okay, I'm looking down on all of you.
There was a stage?
Yes!
There was always a stage.
It was in the back corner.
Of course, every maid cafe is gonna have a stage.
Well, not everyone.
But...
Most, I suppose.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
Okay.
I'm gonna sing something...
Halloween.
Because I won't sing it tomorrow.
This might be a little weird for the mood.
Actually, no.
It's not weird for the mood.
Oh, wait.
Well, it's not the Halloween song.
I changed my mind.
Okay.
One second.
I don't wanna take too long because...
I...
I've planned on...
I didn't want this to be over two hours.
So...
Okay.
I think this...
Hold on, let me double check.
I think this is okay.
Okay.
I sing...
What
a thrill With darkness and silence through the night What a thrill I'm searching and I'll melt into you What a fear in my heart But here I am You're so supreme I give my life Not for honor But for you In my time There'll be no one else My voice, oh god Crime It's the way I fly to you I'm still in a dream Snake Eater
Someday you'll go through the rain And someday you'll feed on a tree frog This ordeal, the trial, to survive For the day we see new light I give my life, my forerunner,
my time There'll be no one else Sorry Crime is the way I fly to you I'm still in a dream, snake it all
I'm still in a dream, snake it all
Snake it all Come on now
Come on now You really thought I had like no Metal Gear related toggle?
Really?
At all?
You thought I had nothing?
You just like, you were like, oh I guess she just didn't want anything Come on, I have Delvely's eyepatch
That's boss minto to you Yay, Snake Eater Okay, tonight I brought together a group of gorlies that, for most of them Except like one That I have always wanted to sing with I just kind of, for some of them I've been talking with them a little bit more lately And so I know some people might be like,
woah, woah, I didn't even know you talked with that person Yeah, we do sometimes, I don't always talk about who I'm talking with in my DMs
But yeah, I got stuff going on, I've been reaching out of my comfort zone a little bit And I'm really really grateful because all these lovely ladies were, all of them are so busy And so I am really really grateful that they all took time to join me for this Even though they're just so nice,
some of them were just like, oh my gosh, it's my honor And I'm like, no, it's my honor To sing with you, my voice is really not doing so well today But this is all just for fun
Hopefully I can sing with more people in the future I was just like, oh my gosh, I want to sing with so many people But I also, like I said, I didn't want this to be super duper long So it might kind of be, not a speedrun, but just kind of, let's sing some songs!
Some duets So I'm going to scoot over And I'm going to introduce the first person, which probably no one is surprised about Oh, wait, hold on
Hi everybody, Matara Comedy Shoujo here, and this is my favorite song in Citadel Space You will not get that reference I don't get that reference I'm a little bit nervous, I'm not going to lie, but here we go I'm nervous too I love you Mint
I sing while belting Well, my girl's in the next room.
Sometimes I wish she was you.
I guess we never heard of these lyrics.
I haven't listened to these.
It's really good to hear your voice.
Say my name, it sounds so sweet.
Coming from the lips of an angel.
Hearing those words, it makes me weak.
And I never wanna say goodbye.
But girl, you make it hard to be faithful.
With the lips of an angel.
It's funny that you're calling me tonight.
And yes, I've dreamt of you too.
But they were more like nightmares.
And does he know you're talking to me?
Will it start a fight?
No, I don't think she has a clue.
Well, my girl's in the next room.
Sometimes I wish she was you.
I guess we never really moved on.
It's really good to hear your voice.
Say my name, it sounds so sweet.
Coming from the lips of an angel.
Hearing those words, it makes me weak.
And I never wanna say goodbye.
But girl, you make it hard to be faithful.
With the lips of an angel.
Emotional, emotional, okay.
It's really good to hear your voice.
Say my name, it sounds so sweet.
Coming from the lips of an angel.
Hearing those words, it makes me weak.
And I never wanna say goodbye.
But girl, you make it hard to be faithful.
With the lips of an angel.
Goodbye, but girl, you make it hard to be faithful.
Thanks, Matara!
Honey, why you calling me so late?
I love you, Mint.
I love you, Wisp.
I almost called you guys Momo.
Get out of here.
Don't call them Momo's.
I love you, Wisp.
I love you, Mint.
Big kisses.
Have an amazing rest of your day and enjoy this wonderful day.
Filled with spooks and celebration.
Bye-bye!
And remember, I am Matara Khan.
And you can bug me anytime.
Bye, honey.
Get out of here!
She's such a yapper.
Thank you, Matara!
Thank you, thank you!
Oh my goodness, that girl.
She actually filmed that, I think, the day she was starting her sub-a-thon.
I was like, um, Matara, unless you decide to record it during your sub-a-thon, can I get it today?
And she was like, yeah.
Like I said, everyone is so busy.
And I felt so bad bugging people.
I felt so bad.
But I'm really happy that so many people decided to join in.
The next one is probably not a surprise either.
But this is a song that I've never sung before.
Also, I don't know if it's obvious, but I've never listened to these videos before.
If the audio is too loud or too quiet, just let me know.
I kind of wanted to keep them a surprise.
Oh shoot,
I...
I think I'll be okay.
This one might be a little scuffed.
But that's okay.
That's okay.
Okie dokie.
Okie dokie, okie dokie.
Let me put the notifications up.
There we go.
Okie dokie, okie dokie.
Thank you guys for all the gifted memberships.
Thank you guys for all the superchats.
Thank you!
Okie dokie.
No, sorry.
Dokie is not...
You guys, I'm going to have a literal concert with Dokie, okay?
If you want to hear me and Dokie sing, you gotta come to our concert.
I can't spoil it here.
Gosh.
You gotta come to the concert.
Sheesh.
Alright, our next person.
Kikariki!
This is Takanashi Kiana from Hololive English.
Hey!
My favorite little ghost maid, Minto!
Let's sing together to celebrate the day.
Yeah!
A Hello Project song.
A Morning Musume song.
Yes!
Let's go!
Oh, this is my part.
I'm so frustrated, I could cry.
As time goes by, as the sky goes by, and when we are connected, will this planet be beautiful?
What kind of voice will make you smile?
Will we meet again in the next life?
It's so painful.
I know the distant future, but I can't decide what will happen tomorrow.
It's not like how I usually feel.
Oh, my heart.
I love you, I love you.
I feel your preciousness.
I close my eyes and feel you.
As time goes by, as the sky goes by, and when we are connected, will this planet be beautiful?
Giwawa.
Giwawa, I'm gonna haunt you.
Giwawa, my ushi.
Giwawa, she smells so good.
Giwawa.
The wind's soliloquy.
He loves you.
The continuation of a dream.
The continuation of that is...
I
love you, I love you, I love you, I love you I feel it I close my eyes, I close my eyes I feel you Ah, ah, ah Beyond time, beyond time Beyond the sky, beyond the sky By the time we are connected Ah, ah, ah Will this planet be beautiful?
Oh my gosh!
Ah!
Fauna!
Oh my god!
Fauna, thank you for the friend!
Ah, thank you!
Hello, saplings!
Welcome back!
Oh, oh, oh, wait, that's her.
Oops!
Yay!
Thank you so much for having me!
That was fun singing together!
Thank you!
I love you!
And have a beautiful time for the rest of the stream!
Thank you!
Yay, yay, yay, yay, yay, yay, yay!
Thank you, Kiwamo!
Thank you, thank you!
That was Toki wo Koe, Sora wo Koe by Morning Musume!
Yay!
Maybe I should have written the setlist.
My bad, sorry.
I'm nervous.
I'm really... Oh my gosh!
Thank you!
Oh my gosh, thank you!
Sorry, I'm really nervous.
And now I had...
Oh my gosh, Fauna, I was watching you!
I was watching you right before I started!
Thank you for writing!
You're so cute in 3D!
Oh my gosh, and your dancing skeletons and everything!
I'm a big fan of Fauna.
Wow, I'm really honored.
Oh my gosh, thank you!
Thank you guys!
Thank you so much!
And...
Yeah!
So...
I have...
4 more people!
Oh gosh, I'm shaking.
I'm shaking!
The next person is another...
Another...
Vtuber with an amazing, amazing voice.
Again, I'm very honored.
Especially because she's also so busy.
It's funny because...
I actually have 2 Chaperone songs.
In this.
And...
I mean...
I don't know if anybody's curious, but...
But...
I mean, this is my debut.
Of course it's archived!
So...
Yeah, the next person is...
Someone I also really look up to.
And I think is a great streamer.
Mousy!
Hello!
She's so small.
The arms are like an angel through the glass on roof.
I don't wanna call it off.
But you don't wanna call it love.
Only wanna be the one that I call baby.
You can kiss a hundred boys in bars.
Show another shot, I'm trying to stop the feeling.
You can say it's just the way you are.
Make a new excuse, another stupid reason.
Good luck, babe.
Well, good luck babe.
You have to stop the world just to stop the feeling.
Good luck babe.
Well well well.
Well good luck babe.
Well baby boy.
You have to stop the world just to stop the feeling.
You can say.
Well who cares?
It's a sexually explicit kinda love affair.
And I cry.
It's not fair.
I just need a little love and I just need a little air.
Think I'm gonna call it off, even if you call it love.
I just wanna love someone who calls me baby.
You can kiss a hundred boys in bars, Shoot another shot, try to stop the feeling.
You can say it's just the way you are, Make a new excuse, another stupid reason.
Well, good luck, babe.
You'd have to stop the world just to stop the feeling.
When
you wake up next to him in the middle of the night, With your head in your hands, you're nothing more than his wife.
And when you think about me all of those years ago, You're standing face to face with, I told you so.
You know I hate to say that I told you so.
You know I hate to say it, but I told you so.
You can kiss a hundred boys in bars, Shoot another shot, try to stop the feeling.
You can say it's just the way you are, Make a new excuse, another stupid reason.
Well, good luck, babe.
You'd have to stop the world just to stop the feeling.
Thank you, Mousy!
Oh my god, so cute.
I love you, bye!
Oh my gosh, I love her Halloween outfit.
So cute!
Yay!
That was good luck, babe.
With Iron Mouse!
Thank you!
Oh wait, I think I put both of the Chapel Road songs next to each other.
I didn't mean to.
Oh no, I didn't.
Oh my gosh, this next one though, I'm really nervous about.
Because I practiced it, but honestly, I chose this song with my own selfish reasoning.
Because I thought that this singer, I thought that she could do a really, really great job with it.
And I felt bad because she didn't know the song.
And then I was like, wait, we can change it.
I know you're busy.
And she was like, no, I'll learn it.
And she's just the sweetest person ever.
I'd like to welcome to the stage...
Liz!
Let me get smaller.
I, I just woke up from a dream.
Where you and I had to say goodbye.
And I don't know what it all means.
But since I survived, I realized.
Wherever you go, that's where I'll follow.
Nobody's promise tomorrow.
So I'ma love you every night like it's the last night.
Like it's the last night.
If the world was ending, I'd wanna be next to you.
If the party was over and our time on earth was through.
I'd wanna hold you just for a while.
And die with a smile.
If the world was ending, I'd wanna be next to you.
Lost, lost in the words that we scream.
I don't even wanna do this anymore.
Cause you already know what you mean to me.
And our love's the only war worth fighting for.
Wherever you go, that's where I'll follow.
Nobody's promise tomorrow.
So I'ma love you every night like it's the last night.
Like it's the last night.
If the world was ending, I'd wanna be next to you.
If the party was over and our time on earth was through.
I'd wanna hold you just for a while.
And die with a smile.
If the world was ending, I'd wanna be next to you.
Oh gosh, I completely forgot.
You guys, I'm so starstruck.
I'm next to you.
She just sounds so good.
Next to you.
Right next to you.
If the world was ending, I'd wanna be next to you.
If the party was over and our time on earth was through.
I'd wanna hold you just for a while.
And die with a smile.
If the world was ending, I'd wanna be next to you.
I'd wanna be next to you.
Oh my gosh, thank you.
Thank you so much for having me on your special day.
Thank you so much.
It means the world to me to sing with you.
I wanna be next to you.
I wanna be next to Maid Mint.
Thank you so much.
Have a great rest of your stream.
Yes!
Oh my gosh.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
There she goes.
Oh my gosh.
The cutest, the beautifullest.
Oh my gosh, I'm so sorry.
I kind of... you guys are for real.
I chose that song from my own selfish desires.
I was just like she will kill this song.
And hopefully she sings it again in karaoke.
Oh my gosh, she's so... I know I'm like totally debuffing myself.
Because I chose like the most incredible singers ever.
But it's really just because I wanted to hear them sing.
It's really just my own selfish.
I wanna hear these beautiful people sing in my ears.
I'm the winner.
Even if I sound so bad next to them.
The next person is also just the most incredible singer ever.
And someone I've been talking to more recently.
And, you know, everybody... Oh my gosh.
Everybody's just been so kind.
Hold on, my YouTube froze again.
I just...
Just having so many... so many...
Hopefully I can do a revenge of that song.
I'll ask Elizabeth if I can use her vocals again.
Or something, I don't know, but...
Just all the support, the amount of support that you guys have all shown me and so many other Vtubers.
All my friends too, so...
Sorry, oh gosh.
So, sorry.
I'm really starstruck and just nervous.
I sound like Dookie.
We'll do revenge tomorrow.
Okay,
next one is with the beautiful, the talented, everybody loves her.
I love her, maybe the most.
No, I'm just kidding.
I don't think so.
I think the jailbirds probably love her the most.
Please!
Hold on, I'm gonna take another sippy.
Let's go!
Nerissa!
Nerissa Ravencroft!
Yeah!
Happy Halloween!
5, 6, 5, 6, 7, 8!
Doing it with me!
Oh,
I said her part on accident!
I'm sorry, Nerissa!
I woke up alone, staring at my ceiling.
I try not to care, but it hurts my feelings.
You don't have to stare, come here, get with it.
No one's touched me there in a damn hot minute.
And baby, don't you like this beat?
I made it so you'd sleep with me.
It's like 199 degrees when you're doing it with me, doing it with me.
H-O-T-T-O-G-O, you can clap and touch your toes.
Now raise your hands and body roll.
Dance it out, you're hot to go.
H-O-T-T-O-G-O, snap and clap and touch your toes.
Raise your hands, now body roll.
H-O-T-T-O-G-O.
H-O-T-T-O-G-O, you can take me hot to go.
What's it take to get your number?
What's it take to bring you home?
Hurry up, it's time for supper.
Order up, I'm hot to go.
What's it take to get your number?
Hurry up, I'm scotting cold.
Hurry up, it's time for supper.
Hurry up, it's time to go.
H-O-T-T-O-G-O, you can take me hot to go.
It's hot in here.
Is anyone else hot?
Yeah, I'm hot.
You're coming home with me?
Yeah.
Okay.
It's hot.
Oh my god.
I'll call the cab.
Thanks for having me!
I love
her so much.
Oh my gosh.
Nerissa Ravencroft, everybody.
Thank you!
I'm so sorry I sang over your one part.
Nerissa, I was just too excited.
I was just too excited to sing with you.
Yeah!
Okay, I have one last person that I'd like to sing with.
Which, actually, a lot of people were like, who is this?
And I want to say, last night, Raora DMed me and she was just like, Mint, I'm looking forward to your 3.0!
And I was like, Raora, grazie!
But also, I'm so sorry.
I chose that oshi mark to throw people off the scent, but it was because it's someone cat related, but I didn't want to use their oshi mark.
And so, I was like, I'm so sorry if people were confused.
But I would love, Raora, if you ever want to sing one day.
I would be so honored to sing with a big cat.
I want to sing with so many people.
Like I said, I wanted to sing with so many more people.
I wanted to sing with...
It's funny, I chose Bishoujo and Hololive, but I wanted to sing with indies as well, and just so many people.
I wanted to sing with lots of friends.
But, like I said, there's lots of people in the video game.
Why did I say it like that?
In the game that I made with the team.
So, you can check them out in there too and everything.
Why is everybody saying, Germa, stop!
Stop, you're ruining my wholesome moment.
Stop!
Video game.
The last song is with someone very special to me, of course.
Hold on.
Let me make sure I have the right lyrics.
Someone very special to me, and of course, who else would that be except...
My mama!
Why are you guys saying, Mr. Beast, Kojima, stop!
You're ruining my wholesome... Stop!
Don't!
Spaghetti!
Stop it!
Oh my gosh.
Ayami mama!
This is the last song of the night, everybody.
Thank you for coming out.
Stick around though, because I want you to see my ending screen too.
It's cute.
Hello.
Hi, everyone.
I'm Ayami.
I'm an illustrator and VTuber and...
Yeah!
Me too.
You?
Mama!
Yeah!
Let's go!
I am a dreamer.
Hidden power.
Mama is cute.
Hihihihi!
I'm not in a hurry.
I want to find it.
I want to make it come true.
I believe that there's nothing that cannot be overcome.
Like a song, like a miracle, emotions change everything.
I'm gonna sing it.
I'm sure, I'm sure.
It's probably...
The mic.
I am a dreamer.
Hidden power.
A world
I have yet to see.
No matter what is waiting for me there.
Even if it's different from my ideals.
I have no fear.
The birds are riding on the wind.
I'm going on a journey.
From today to tomorrow.
I want to tell you.
I want to scream.
I'm the only one in this world.
Like a prayer.
Like a star.
It's a small light.
But someday.
More.
I want to be stronger.
There is no limit.
The possibilities are here.
In this hand.
It's gonna be your world.
I want to find it.
I want to make it come true.
I believe.
That's all.
There is nothing I can't overcome.
Like singing.
Like a miracle.
My feelings.
Will change everything.
I'm sure.
I'll be so surprised.
Push!
Congratulations!
Thank you!
I love you!
Thank you everyone!
Thank you!
I love you.
Yummy mama everybody!
I got really emotional during that.
I have one last song that I would like to sing.
It's a Halloween song.
It's not very long.
Thank you guys again for the 3.0 debut and everything.
Thank you guys!
I really appreciate everybody being here.
And all the support.
Please continue to support me!
Thank you!
I don't want the mash.
It's not the mash!
This is a little more wholesome.
Like I said, it's a Halloween song.
I mean, unless you want the mash.
I'll give you the mash.
Last song.
And then I will see you tomorrow for karaoke!
We'll do the mash tomorrow.
No, we do not want it.
Are you sure?
I don't know.
I see a lot of yeses.
OK, last song is wholesome.
OK guys, it's wholesome.
Wholesome vibes.
Wholesome vibes for my wholesome debut, OK?
This one is from a...
Actually, I was watching...
They did a concert because this show has been around for 10 years.
And they did a concert for it recently.
Just a couple days ago.
And I was watching it and I was like...
Oh my gosh, I was crying.
It was so beautiful.
And it's from a show that I love very very much.
Called Over the Garden Wall that I watch every Halloween.
So I will sing Into the Unknown.
I'm really sorry if there was volume stuff too.
I'm really sorry if there was volume stuff with everybody.
I was trying to adjust while singing.
All that was lost is revealed Our long bygone burdens Mere echoes of the spring But where have we come And where shall we end If dreams can't come true Then why not pretend?
How the gentle wind beckons through the leaves As autumn colors fall Dancing in a swirl of golden memories The loveliest lights of all
Yay!
Okay, you guys convinced me.
You guys convinced me.
Oh shoot, where's my lyrics?
Uh-oh.
Wait, where's my lyrics?
Oh no!
Wait, hold on!
I'm gonna start over.
I was heading to a yacht late last night When my eyes beheld a skippity sigh Where the Sigmarusler began to rise And violently mock the Costco guys He did the mash He rinsed the bobs and gats He put the fries in the pan He did the mash He gave him a smash or a pat He did the mash He rinsed up all the gats From the back rooms in the Ohio streets Where the wolf inside me Last and least!
The gooners all jelled to grow their choads Didn't give tips from me cause I'm a Loot Smacks pro!
He rizzed up all the gads Gave them a smash or a pass They put the fries in the bag He rizzed up all the gads The streamers were all doing the gritty Baby Gronk just rizzed up Lizzy The Rizzler brought big justice Aiden Ross and Kai's clan There were snowpops inside Everyone began to mew Patrick Vabe bit on Oxclay One,
two, three, buckle my shoe!
Blue Tie Kid was on his Sigma grind I don't know... Strixum Prime!
He rizzed up all the gads Gave them a smash or a pass They put the fries in the bag He rizzed up all the gads Pausing his stream, Mint Phantom did yak Seems like Doki Bird was about to cap Looked around to see if there was enough movement and said Did you guys know the low taper meme is still massive?
He rizzed up all the gads Gave them a smash or a pass They put the fries in the bag He rizzed up all the gads Everyone loves Skibity, he's the ultimate Giga Chad And my brain rot bash is the hit of the land For you, the beta, this bash was meant to The funniest meme ever made is HACK TO LAST!
He put the fries in the bag He rizzed up all the gads Gat good!
Easy Matara, you sussy Ohio Gat good!
Gat good!
Easy Matara, easy Matara Gat good!
Thank you guys!
Sorry, I can't think anymore I will have the game up, I'll post about it on Twitter I'll try to remember Blue Sky, I can't remember more than one thing But play the game and Happy Halloween!